good evening i'm denise valdez and i'm
brian loftis after spending five days
away from school because of a rise in
covid cases and staffing issues students
and teachers within ccsd preparing to
head back but the district will still
have a number of empty seats when the
bell rings tomorrow victoria saha shares
where ccsd is at after talking with
parents about the return victoria
this pause gave ccsd nurses time to get
through a backlog of calls as they
process covet cases in the district we
just learned today that between friday
and today staff were in touch with more
than 4 000 parents about their child of
those 2300 will only be able to return
to school tomorrow safely and more than
1400 employees were contacted and more
than one thousand will be able to go
back to school to go back to work
tomorrow excuse me still some parents
have mixed feelings about the return
two thousand employees and students will
not be coming back to school just yet on
wednesday but we found many going back
to school soaking up the last day of the
paws at our local parks it's stressful
just stressful we spoke to pamela sedasi
she's sending her kids back to school
wednesday but still worries for their
safety my biggest concern is send them
back to school
because kids they take off they mess and
they cough on each other making sure
students follow a strict mask policy is
a top concern for parent terence jones i
think the only thing i think of when it
comes to the teachers is making sure
that they stay within the policy make
sure they
treat the kids like as if they're adults
when it comes to those type of
procedures something his daughter elena
is struggling with it's not really that
fun because we have to just
keep our mask on even though every kid
doesn't like to keep their mask on
although parents have their reservations
about school reopening wednesday some
say they don't think a five-day pause
was necessary we have to live with it
how how can you do this all the time
like you know you're going to keep the
kids away from school
and to make up for the missed school
days the school district says students
will now have classes on february 7 and
april 25th those were originally
scheduled as days off in the school
calendar denise victoria thanks for that
and just ahead of the return to class we
put up a poll on twitter asking you how
you would grade the district's response
to the recent covid surge well the top
answer was an f with more than half of
the votes a or b got the second most
votes